luca ist ein system springer ein kind
das nirgendwo klarkommt eigentlich aber
halt sucht er schlägt oft um sich gegen
sachen gegen menschen als gehostete und
aufgewachsen wo fast umgebracht ab und
auch einen erwachsenen eine ahnung
gedreht habe und ja dann bin ich so was
wie ein heim gekommen
wieso bist ein junger lieber netter
junge
er hat nicht anders kennen öfters wird
auszukosten
[Musik]
auch ghana war eine system springerin
sobald eine situation nicht so war wie
es sie wollte bin ich ausgerastet
betreuerinnen brauchen gute nerven
das kommt durchaus auch mal vor dass
einem vor die füße oder ins gesicht
gerutscht wird oft werden diese kinder
von einer einrichtung in die nächste
abgeschoben bei ihnen versagt das
hilfesystem
auf steigert sich seine wut bis hin zu
massiver gewalt
ich hab ne lehrer beleidigt kompletter
und ausgerastet
ich hoffe mal beim fußballverein habe
ich mein mitspieler und verprügelt und
ich hoffen trainer gehört sowie nach
schule rausgeflogen tritt ja den gegen
türen fenster und alles dreht ja voll ab
und den ich bringe euch oben den renter
und der villa irgendwas in hand nehmen
auch messer oder nicht und dann muss man
schnell sein
und bevor es böse wird bringe ich mein
zimmer und den treter der uptempo data
und macht und bild zerstören ohne ende
und wenn das nicht aufwendig von draußen
paar mal rufen solche attacken müssen
lukas betreuerinnen alltäglich aushalten
der bremer kinderpsychologe und forscher
stefan rücker berät jugendämter und
heime bei besonders schwierigen kindern
für ihn ist klar mit heftigen
aggressionen zeigen sie dass sie
eigentlich nähe suchen
doch bevor sie sich auf eine neue
bindung einlassen können müssen sie ihre
betreuer austesten
ein wichtiges erfordernis ist dass man
die ursachen versteht wenn ich von einem
kind angegriffen werde
und das gefühl habe das kind greift mich
persönlich an ist es viel schwerer
auszuhalten dass wenn ich den
hintergrund habe dass das kind
traumatisiert ist und sein traum marie
inszeniert und eigentlich projiziert
mich gar nicht meins dann nämlich als
projektionsfläche in diesem fall braucht
für die kinder hat das durchaus logisch
wenn ich dich jetzt schlage wenn ich
dich missbillige und abwehrte dann will
ich wissen wie du reagierst das läuft
natürlich nicht bewusst ab sondern vor
bewusst vielleicht sogar unbewusst aber
letztlich erfüllt ist die funktion zu
prüfen bleibst du bei mir oder werden
lässt du dich auch ab wie alle andere
schon als baby nimmt das jugendamt luca
aus der familie gibt ihn in eine
notunterkunft für säuglinge
dann kommt er zurück zu seinen eltern
denn die rückführung in die familie gilt
als oberstes ziel der jugendhilfe doch
bei luca geht das schief
er hat wieder auffällige verletzungen
prellungen an rücken und gesäß wieder
wird er den eltern entzogen kommt erst
in eine pflegefamilie dann ins
kinderheim in die psychiatrie in mehrere
wohngruppen immer wieder kümmern sich
neue betreuer um ihn und kommen doch
nicht mit luca zurecht je mehr vertrauen
enttäuscht wird desto schwieriger wird
es für system sprenger wie luca sich auf
neue bindungen einzulassen
kinder machen ablehnung erfahrungen die
erleben bindung von beziehungs abrisse
das ist die ursache des problems und das
system verschärft das problem auch noch
mal diese kinder werden nicht zu system
sprengen so dass das system macht sie zu
system sprengen
wichtig ist hier frühzeitig auf den fall
verlauf zu schauen dass manche erkennen
kann dass sich so eine hilfe karriere
abzeichnet was natürlich schwierig ist
wenn die gebietskörperschaft gewechselt
wird kein kind ist von anbeginn an ein
system sprenger es ist eine lange
entwicklung meist beginnt es damit dass
das jugendamt eine kindeswohlgefährdung
sieht dann nimmt es den jungen oder das
mädchen aus dem elternhaus vorübergehend
kommt es in ein kinderheim bis die
behörden eine pflegefamilie gefunden
haben wenn der junge oder das mädchen
sich dort anderen kindern gegenüber
aggressiv verhält kommt es in eine
notunterkunft bis eine neue familie oder
ein anderes kinderheim gefunden wurde
hören die probleme nicht auf steht der
nächste wechsel an oft in die kinder-
und jugendpsychiatrie
während sie dort behandelt werden muss
wieder ein neues heim oder die nächste
wohngruppe gesucht werden
so kommen schnell mehr als zehn wechsel
zustande
bis hin ins jugendgefängnis sollten sie
sogar straftaten begehen und jeder
wechsel der fördert die angst des kindes
und seine maßlose wut system springer
sind ja junge menschen die alle
überfordern
und dann ist es so dass diese kinder
bestenfalls in der hoffnung und andere
hilfesysteme übergeleitet werden dass
ihnen dort besser geholfen werden kann
oder schlechterdings damit man eben ein
schwieriges kind los ist das heißt also
die kinder werden weiter gereicht weil
das jeweilige setting nicht in der lage
ist die entsprechende hilfe anzubieten
in ostfriesland gehört es zum konzept
genau das zu verhindern
in dieser intensiv wohngruppe kümmern
sich jeweils zwei bis drei betreuer und
nur vier jugendliche manche von ihnen
haben tagsüber zusätzlich eine ambulante
einzelbetreuung
astrid baumann leitet die wohngruppe ihr
mann ist professor für intensiv
pädagogik und fachberater vieler
jugendhilfeträger er plädiert für
maßgeschneiderte hilfen bei denen
jugendamt und hilfe träger sich vorab
schon genauestens abstimmen welche
maßnahmen notwendig sind
das ist aber nicht selbstverständlich
manche and agiert mit abwehr wegen der
hohen kosten manche sind dankbar dass
man versucht den kindern wirklich
gerecht zu werden
im jahr 2009 10 haben die behörden 1,2
millionen mal eingegriffen um kindern
und jugendlichen zu helfen die maßnahmen
reichen von erziehungshilfen über
unterbringung in tageseinrichtungen bis
zu intensive einzelbetreuung
von den 1,2 millionen kindern und
jugendlichen wurden etwa 264.000 aus
ihren familien genommen
die mehrheit kam dann in kinderheime und
die übrigen in pflegeheime experten
schätzen dass in deutschland 8000 bis
13.000 kinder so auffällig sind dass sie
häufig die einrichtungen wechseln müssen
sie sind die so genannten system
sprenger
carla die ihren wirklichen namen nicht
nennen will ist nach einer langen
odyssee durch die einrichtungen in einer
der wohngruppen von baumann gelandet
dort hat sie drei jahre gelebt mit 17
ist sie ausgezogen
jetzt geht die 20 jährige in ihrer
eigenen wohnung in oldenburg und macht
eine ausbildung zur altenpflegerin
ihre eltern waren mit carla von beginn
an überfordert
ich wurde mit 2 ins kinderheim abgegeben
und von dort aber nicht eigentlich zu
pflegefamilien wieder ins heim gekommen
drei schläge familien waren es insgesamt
und irgendwann bin ich dann durch die
wogen gruppen gelaufen in acht
verschiedenen wohngruppen brachte das
jugendamt sie unter hat sie immer
weitergereicht
und mit jedem mal stiegen carlos
enttäuschung unschuld ich habe mich ganz
ganz toll ungeliebt gefühlt weil ich
dachte niemand möchte mich haben und
niemand könnte mich aushalten
das war ganz ganz schlimm für mich
meistens was auch trauer und ich habe
das aber tatsächlich in gut geäußert
carla hat erlebt was es heißt fixiert zu
werden
das war wenn ich dann zu doll
ausgelastet bin wurde dann aber zur
strafe auch so ein fixiert sein und auf
in den ruheraum geschoben der nur weiß
war mit kameras und sagt dabei dicht und
lang und natürlich habe ich angst
bekommen und weitergemacht und habe
natürlich auch geweint und manaus gerast
und habe geschrien bis nach vier stunden
meinen körper irgendwann nicht mehr
konnte und nicht eingeschlafen bin das
ist ganz schlimm für sein kind aus
mitzuerleben
mit 14 jahren kommt sie in die
wohngruppe von betreuerinnen vivien
kauer und fasst nach und nach vertrauen
[Musik]
es hat eine ganze zeit lang gedauert bis
sie überhaupt angefangen hat ihre tasche
auszuräumen
sie wollte einfach vorbereitet sein dass
wenn man ihr sagt so und jetzt ist es
soweit und jetzt geht zum nächsten dass
sie dann die tasche schon gepackt hat
und dann wieder gehen muss so wie sie
das vorher kannte
carla hatte große angst die sich immer
wieder in schlimmen wutausbrüchen
äußerte
ich habe wäschekörbe zertrümmert alles
was im weg stand wird kaputt gemacht ich
habe radfahren und besteck durch die
gegend geschmissen also alles was mir in
die finger kam wurde eigentlich kreuz
und quer durch die gegend geschmissen
das gab auch den einen oder anderen
moment wo ich dachte ich kann es jetzt
nicht nachvollziehen und jetzt ziemlich
gemacht dass jetzt selber auf wütend
aber es ist ja auch unser konzept und
auch unser anspruch an uns und egal wie
die kinder sich verhalten das wir eine
gewisse logik der kinder dahinter sehen
und wir wollen versuchen diese logik des
kindes dahinter zu verstehen und dann
haben wir mal dasselbe gemacht paradoxe
intervention gespielt quasi und sie war
ganz verdutzt warum warum schreien die
betreuer jetzt rum warum irgendwie
schmeißen die betreuer jedes
lebensmittel durch die gegend und dann
sind wir darüber auch ins gespräch
gekommen das ausschlaggebende was am
ende das verändert hat die situation war
einfach dass ich egal was war keine
strafe bekommen habe
also wenn ich gewollt habe dann war
nicht die strafe darf nicht mehr
rausgehen sondern das was in der
situation vorkommen wie zum beispiel am
handy kaputt gemacht hatte ich halt drei
wochen lang einen die mir bis ich dann
irgendwann neues leisten konnte oder so
es war einmal situationsgerecht
gehandelt
für carla war es eine große
erleichterung nicht ständig für ihr
verhalten bestraft zu werden
so konnte sie bald vertrauen fassen und
ihr verhalten ändern
mit 14 wurde richard ich ich habe immer
noch aus gras so ist nicht aber ich hab
mich echt aufgepasst dass da nichts mehr
kaputt geht und stück für stück habe ich
ganz viel aufgearbeitet und habe mit den
betreuungskräften auch wirklich gelernt
loszulassen mal zu weinen will die
gefühle zu sprechen aber dafür ganz ganz
viel auch mit mir gearbeitet auch um
einen schulabschluss zu schaffen
noch heute ist vivien mit einigen
stunden wöchentlich für carla zuständig
sie unterstützt sie zum beispiel bei
behördengängen ärztin angela merkel
betreut im pulli klinikum haldensleben
immer wieder system sprenger wie luca
diese kinder werden psychologisch
behandelt und medikamentös eingestellt
kinder so zu erleben ist auch für die
ärztin nicht leicht empfunden habe ich
eine traurigkeit von dem was dieses kind
vorliegt hat aber ehrlich gesagt wir
sehen es nicht zu selten also es gibt
kinder die im keller eingesperrt
zusammen mit dem hund von teller essen
müssen
und wenn sie so eine dinge immer wieder
hören oder oft hören ich bin inzwischen
27 jahre hier in der klinik
ich bin nicht sagen man stumpft ab aber
es ist immer wieder neue schlimm
ergotherapie tiergestützte therapie
gruppentherapie psychologische
einzelgespräche es gibt viele ansätze
doch man kann nur an der symptomatik
arbeiten die aggressivität herunter
schieben den kindern helfen die impulse
zu kontrollieren
wir versuchen so gut wie möglich zu
arbeiten dass das kind strategien lernt
wenn ich wütend bin was mache ich denn
wie erkenne ich dass ich wütend werde
was kann ich machen stattdessen also es
recht schwierig therapeutisch mit diesen
kindern der sich die kinder gehören in
der kinder und jugendpsychiatrie ban
diesen schweren bindungsstörungen zu der
schwierigsten klientel die es gibt und
von der prognose auch ausgesprochen
schlecht muss man sagen weil luca
besonders betreuungsintensiven hat das
jugendamt einen einzel betreuer für ihn
genehmigt christoph harrach soll sich
nur um ihn kümmern und ganz für luca
dasein in der hoffnung dass der junge
wenigstens zu einem menschen wirklich
vertrauen fasst
doch im wald in der hütte gibt es weder
wasser noch strom aber einen kamin die
gemeinsame arbeit schweißt zusammen
weil ich erst mal einigung ja er ist nie
macht jan hammann erster schon vorher an
die macht marshmallows ist ihr könnt ihr
kind seiner tochter geht sagen dass er
manchmal nicht sagen kann wir zeigen das
war halt nicht so schnell angreifbar ist
ja klar
sind sie jetzt was wie ein vaterersatz
war das kann man nicht sagen das geht
nicht
bleiben die eltern gibt's kein ersatz
für aber ich bin halt für ihn da und das
war es auch was solche line hasst er
braucht einen grünen menschen so besagt
nämlich dass ein kunde sagt gegenüber
vorschriften nach dies du sagst aber
heute einen lockeren dessen wie sie ein
anderes macht so in der woche im wald
hat luca selbstvertrauen aufgebaut und
vertrauen zu christoph gefasst
noch gleichwertig den haag wurden
wanderstock vom feinsten
freue ich mich die nehme ich mit luca
wahnsinnig ist ein lieber junge lieber
netter schlauer
er hat nicht anders keinen öfters jetzt
aus zossen ins umschlägt hat angriff
oder flucht was er braucht ist die
ziehung bindung liebe alles fremd
erkennt hat nur negatives traurig aber
so ist es inzwischen leben lucas eltern
getrennt er wünscht sich kontakt zu
beiden
das war mist damals eigentlich meine
ganze familie hugo kupper pharmazie
schauten sonntag auch den habe ich immer
das essen weggerissen
wir haben nämlich jetzt so ein bisschen
mit kontakt aufbauen
erst mit briefen dann telefonieren
besucher mit betreuer so ohne betreuer
übernachten zum schluss vielleicht wohl
kein star wieder wohnt aber auch ist nun
bei mama und papa wieder zusammen sein
kann würde ich auch lieber erstmal dampf
oder winden dass fragen die könnte so
gesehen haben papa der wirklich
aufgehört hat zu schlagen
doch ob luca irgendwann wieder zu hause
wohnen kann ist ungewiss
christoph hat luca vertrauen gefasst er
muss noch viele gute erfahrungen machen
damit seine seele heilt und er nicht
mehr um sich schlagen muss
[Musik]
[Applaus]